Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
"La belleza es una maldición",
pensó Psique,
mientras miraba el acantilado
donde había sido abandonada por su padre.
Había nacido
con la perfección física tan completa
que fue adorada como la nueva
encarnación de Venus, la diosa del amor.
Pero los amantes humanos de la vida real
estaban demasiado intimidados
incluso para acercarse a ella.
Cuando su padre pidió
consejo al Oráculo de Apolo,
el dios de la luz, la razón y la profecía,
le dijeron que abandonara
a su hija en un acantilado
donde se casaría con un mal alado
cruel y salvaje.
Sola en el acantilado,
Psyche sentía a Zephyr el viento del oeste
levantándola suavemente en el aire.
La puso ante un palacio.
"Estás en casa", dijo una voz invisible.
"Tu marido te espera en el dormitorio,
si te atreves a conocerlo".
Era lo suficientemente valiente,
se dijo Psyche a sí misma.
La habitación estaba tan oscura
que no podía ver a su marido.
Pero no lo sentía como una serpiente.
Su piel era suave, su voz
y su manera eran suaves.
Ella le preguntó quién era él, pero
él dijo que esa era la única pregunta
que él nunca podría contestar.
Si ella lo amaba, no tendría que saberlo.
Sus visitas continuaron noche tras noche.
En poco tiempo, Psique estaba embarazada.
Ella se regocijó,
pero también estaba contrariada.
¿Cómo podía criar a su bebé
con un hombre que nunca había visto?
Esa noche, Psyche se acercó a su marido
durmiente con una lámpara de aceite.
Lo que encontró fue al dios Cupido
que envió dioses y humanos
lujuriosos unos tras otros
con los pinchazos de sus flechas.
Psique dejó caer su lámpara,
quemando a Cupido con aceite caliente.
El dijo que había estado enamorado de
Psique desde que su celosa madre, Venus,
le pidió avergonzar a la joven
pinchándola con una flecha.
Pero arrebatado por la belleza de Psique,
Cupido usó la flecha para sí mismo.
No creía, sin embargo, que los dioses y
los humanos pudieran amar como iguales.
Al conocer su forma real, la esperanza
de felicidad de ella se desvaneció,
así que él se fue lejos.
Psique se quedó desesperada
hasta que la voz invisible volvió
para decirle que era posible
que ella y Cupido se amaran como iguales.
Animada, se dispuso a encontrarlo.
Pero Venus interceptó a Psique y dijo
que ella y Cupido solo podrían casarse
si ella completaba
una serie de tareas imposibles.
Primero, Psyche debía ordenar
una enorme pila de semillas en una noche.
Cuando ella estaba a punto
de abandonar las esperanzas,
una colonia de hormigas tuvo compasión
de ella y la ayudó con el trabajo.
Pasó con éxito la primera prueba.
Después Psique tuvo que traer a Venus
el vellón de la oveja dorada,
que tenía fama de destripar
a aventureros callejeros,
pero un dios del río
le mostró cómo recoger
el vellón que las ovejas
habían enganchado sobre zarzas,
y ella lo logró.
Finalmente, Psique tuvo
que viajar al Inframundo
y convencer a Proserpina,
reina de los muertos,
de poner una gota de su belleza
en una caja para Venus.
Una vez más, la voz invisible
vino a ayudar a Psique.
Dijo que llevara pasteles para Cerberus,
el perro guardián del Inframundo
y dinero para pagar al barquero, Charon
para transportarla por el río Styx.
Con su tercera y última tarea completa,
Psique volvió a la tierra de los vivos.
Justo fuera del palacio de Venus,
abrió la caja de la belleza de Proserpina,
con la esperanza
de guardar algo para ella.
Pero la caja estaba llena de sueño,
no de belleza,
y Psyche se derrumbó en el camino.
Cupido, ahora recuperado de sus heridas,
voló hacia su novia dormida.
Le dijo que se había equivocado.
Su audacia frente a lo desconocido
demostró que era más que su igual.
Cupido le dio a Psique amborsia,
néctar de los dioses, haciéndola inmortal.
Poco después, Psique dio a luz a su hija.
la llamaron Placer,
y ella, Cupido y Psique,
cuyo nombre significa alma,
han estado complicando la vida
amorosa de la gente desde entonces.